mettent des pubs sur des sites avec des fautes de frappe classiques,
puis ramassent sans rien faire des millions
juste parce que vous allez sur gmale.com
ou mikerowesoft.com
(Rires)
Ça parait débile, non ?
Que dites-vous de ceci ?
Le 28 février, un ingénieur d'Amazon
a fait une faute de frappe apparemment mineure.
Je dis apparemment mineure
parce que cette petite faute dans le supercode d'Amazon
a massivement ralenti internet,
coûtant plus de 160 millions de dollars à Amazon
en juste 4 heures.
C'est assez effrayant, en fait.
Récemment, un employé du New England Compound,
un laboratoire pharmaceutique,
a mal nettoyé un labo
et 76 personnes sont mortes
et 700 autres ont attrapé la méningite.
Ces exemples sont dingues, non ?
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés à un monde où ce type d'erreurs,
erreurs de base, « fais-de-ton-mieux », « c'est suffisant », sont acceptables ?
A un moment, nous avons arrêté de valoriser la perfection,
et voilà le résultat.
Je pense que nous devrions tous rechercher la perfection,
tout le temps,
et que nous devrions l'atteindre vite.
Je gère un centre de formation
où je suis responsable de l'instruction de chauffeurs-livreurs.
Dans mon travail,
nous avons une vision très particulière du coût de l'erreur,
du coût de 99%,
car dans le monde des routiers,
ne faire que 99% du boulot veut dire que quelqu'un meurt.
Cent personnes meurent chaque jour
dans un accident de la route.
Réfléchissez-y une seconde.
C'est l'équivalent de 4 collisions d'avions de transport
chaque semaine,
et pourtant nous n'arrivons pas à nous astreindre à nous concentrer au volant.
Donc j'apprends à mes chauffeurs à valoriser la perfection.
C'est pour ça que je leur fais mémoriser
notre programme de conduite défensive en 131 mots
par cœur,
et je le leur fais écrire.
Une faute de terme, d'orthographe, de ponctuation, et le test est raté.
C'est pour ça que j'inspecte les uniformes chaque jour.
Les maillots sont blancs ou bruns.
Les chaussures en cuir lisse noir ou brun
et n'espérez pas rester en cours si vous arrivez tout froissé.
C'est pour ça que j'insiste sur la ponctualité.
Pas de retard : ni en cours, ni en pause, ni au déjeuner.
Si on vous attend quelque part, soyez-y.
Vous voyez, je fais cela pour que mes étudiants comprennent
que quand je les forme à la conduite et que je dis :
« Vérifiez chaque intersection ! »
ils comprennent que ca veut dire chaque feu rouge, chaque carrefour,
chaque petite rue, parking, voie privée, passage piéton,
chaque intersection, sans exception.
Mes étudiants me demandent souvent
pourquoi mes cours sont si difficiles, stricts ou uniformes,
et la réponse est simple.
Le perfectionnisme est une attitude qu'on développe dans les petites choses
pour ensuite l'appliquer à son boulot.
En fait, si on ne sait pas faire bien les petites choses,
on va se planter au moment crucial,
par exemple quand vous êtes au volant.
Une voiture qui roule à 90 km/h
parcourt la longueur d'un terrain de football
en moins de quatre secondes et demie.
Mais il se trouve que c'est aussi le temps
que met une personne pour vérifier un SMS.
Donc je n'autorise pas la déconcentration
ni rien de moins que la perfection chez mes chauffeurs.
Et vous savez quoi ?
J'en ai assez de voir que les gens se contentent de 99%.
Je veux dire, être moins que parfait a ses conséquences, non ?
Réfléchissez-y.
Si les fabricants de cartes de crédit n'étaient efficaces qu'à 99%,
il y aurait en circulation plus d'un million de cartes
qui auraient de mauvaises données sur leur bande magnétique.
Ou si le dictionnaire Webster n'était efficace qu'à 99%,
il contiendrait 470 fautes d'orthographe.
Ça vous parle ?
Si nos médecins n'avaient raison qu'à 99%,
chaque année, 4 453 000 ordonnances seraient mal rédigées.
Et, encore plus inquiétant,
11 nouveaux-nés seraient confiés aux mauvais parents chaque jour
aux États-Unis.
(Rires)
Ce sont juste des probabilités...
La réalité : le gouvernement américain a planté
un avion à 1,4 milliard de dollars
parce que les mécaniciens n'ont fait que 99% du boulot.
Quelqu'un a oublié de vérifier un capteur.
La réalité est que 16 personnes sont mortes,
180 sont blessées,
et 34 millions de voitures sont rappelées
parce que les producteurs d'airbag ont produit et commercialisé un produit
qu'ils pensaient, vous savez, assez bon.
La réalité : les erreurs médicales
sont la 3ème cause de décès en Amérique.
250 000 personnes meurent chaque année
parce que quelqu'un qui pensait faire son boulot assez bien
s'est planté.
Et vous ne me croyez pas ?
Eh bien, je peux comprendre pourquoi.
C'est dur pour nous de croire les gens de nos jours
alors que moins de 50% des informations dans la presse
sont fondées sur des faits.
(Rires)
Tout cela se résume ainsi :
faire de notre mieux ne suffit pas.
Alors comment changer ?
En cherchant la perfection
et en n'acceptant rien de moins.
Je vous donne une minute pour y réfléchir
car je sais ce qu'on vous a dit.
Quelque chose comme : la perfection est impossible pour les humains
donc la rechercher va non seulement détruire votre égo
mais aussi vous vouer à l'échec.
Voilà l'ironie.
Nous avons tous aujourd'hui très peur du mot échec,
mais en réalité, on a besoin d'échouer.
L'échec est une étape naturelle vers la perfection.
Mais parce que nous avons commencé à craindre l'échec
et à craindre l'idée de perfection,
nous l'avons écartée à cause des effets sur notre ego en cas d'échec.
Pensez-vous vraiment que l'échec va vous détruire ?
Ou est-ce juste une réponse facile qui cause des sites web lents,
une médecine et des routes si peu sûres ?
Vous allez faire de la perfection le fautif de cette histoire ?
Voyons, échec et imperfection sont deux choses identiques.
Nous savons que l'imperfection existe autour de nous.
Rien ni personne n'est parfait.
Mais à un moment, parce que c'était trop dur ou douloureux,
nous avons décidé d'ignorer notre capacité à gérer l'échec
et de baisser notre seuil d'acceptation.
Maintenant nous sommes confrontés
à cette nouvelle norme, cette attitude du « assez bon »
et des résultats qui en découlent.
Même après tout cela,
les gens me disent toujours :
« L'équipe médicale les mécaniciens, les ingénieurs,
ils ont fait leur maximum, n'est-ce pas suffisant ? »
Pour être honnête, pas pour moi, surtout dans ces cas-là.
Oui, mais essayer d'être parfait, c'est stressant !
Et puis Oprah en a parlé, les universités ont étudié ça,
même votre conseiller d'orientation vous a averti.
Le stress, c'est mauvais, hein ?
Peut-être,
mais dire que chercher la perfection est stressant,
c'est comme dire que faire de l'exercice est fatigant.
Dans les deux cas, vous voulez le résultat sans faire l'effort.
Honnêtement, dire que chercher la perfection est stressant,
c'est l'excuse des paresseux.
Mais voilà le plus horrible.
De nos jours, les docteurs, les psychologues,
et 10 milliards de dollars de business du développement personnel
s'élèvent tous contre l'idée de perfection
sous le prétexte que cesser de vouloir être parfait
protège la confiance en soi et l'égo.
Mais voilà, ça ne marche pas.
Les groupes d'entraide constatent un taux croissant de récidive
parce qu'ils préfèrent vous apprendre comment accepter d'être un raté,
baisser le seuil d'acceptation,
que vous pousser à être parfait.
Ces docteurs, psychologues et gourous
s'intéressent plus au symptôme qu'au mal.
Le vrai mal de la société actuelle est notre refus d'affronter l'échec.
Nous préférons regarder nos efforts
que de nous attacher aux résultats.
Comme au collège Jérôme Dublin en Ohio,
où ils désignent 30% d'une promotion comme majors de promotion.
Non mais, sérieusement !
Quelqu'un avait la meilleure moyenne.
Je vous garantis qu'ils n'étaient pas 72 ex-aequo.
(Rires)
Mais nous préférons proposer une solution égalitaire
plutôt qu'affronter l'échec, le perdant ou l'échec scolaire.
Chacun a un prix, chacun est promu,
chacun est augmenté malgré les résultats,
et le perfectionniste en nous en vient à se dire,
que dois-je faire pour m'améliorer ?
Comment puis-je me distinguer ?
Et en continuant à promouvoir cette culture,
où personne n'échoue, où on ne dit à personne qu'il va échouer,
alors personne ne réalisera son vrai potentiel non plus.
L'échec et la perte sont nécessaires pour le succès.
Se contenter de l'échec en revanche, non.
Michel Ange aurait dit que le plus grand danger pour la plupart d'entre nous
n'est pas de viser trop haut et de rater,
mais de viser trop bas et réussir.
L'échec devrait être une motivation,
pas une pauvre excuse pour laisser tomber.
Donc j'ai une idée.
Plutôt que de définir le perfectionnisme comme un refus destructeur de l'échec,
pourquoi ne pas lui donner une nouvelle définition ?
Et définir le perfectionnisme comme la volonté de faire ce qui est difficile
pour accomplir ce qui est bien ?
Alors nous sommes d'accord,
l'échec est bon pour notre recherche de perfection.
Si nous cherchons la perfection sans peur d'échouer,
imaginez ce que nous pourrions accomplir !
Comme la star de la NBA Steph Curry :
qui a mis 77 paniers à 3 points d'affilée.
Pensez-y.
Ce type a fait rentrer une balle de 24 cm
dans une cercle de 46 cm suspendu à 3 mètres du sol
à 7,3 mètres de distance
près de 80 fois sans échec.
Ou comme les programmeurs informatiques
du géant aérospatial Lockheed Martin
qui ont écrit un programme
qui utilise 420 000 lignes de code quasi-parfait
pour contrôler chaque étape de l'allumage de 2 millions de tonnes de carburant
pour mettre une fusée de 120 tonnes en orbite.
Ou encore comme ces chercheurs
du Childern's Mercy Hospital à Kansas City dans le Missouri,
qui ont élaboré un outil
pour coder le génome humain en juste 26 heures.
Cet outil est capable de diagnostiquer les maladies génétiques
chez les bébés et nouveaux-nés plus tôt,
permettant aux docteurs d'anticiper les traitements
et potentiellement de sauver la vie du bébé.
Voilà ce qui arrive quand on cherche la perfection.
Peut-être devrait-on être comme l'athlète professionnel,
ou comme le programmeur infatigable,
ou le chercheur passionné.
Alors on cesserait de craindre l'échec
et on cesserait de vivre dans un monde rempli des conséquences
du « assez bon ».
Merci.
(Applaudissements)